the children were right a gruesome
creature lurks under your bed and yes it
wants to suck your blood swelling to
twice its size in the process its name
sigh mcc's lectularius aka the common
bedbug turns out these creatures have
tormented humans for thousands of years
ancient Egyptians for example use spells
to try and fight the insect hordes but
to no avail and while our weapons have
come a long way since spell-casting
we're struggling more than ever to fend
off these pesky pests in the 20th
century humans developed a new weapon
against the bedbug toxic chemicals
pesticides like DDT nearly wiped out
entire populations in most Western
countries but even that wasn't enough by
the turn of the millennium bed bug
populations resurged worldwide and this
time they had new weapons against us
like 15% thicker skin to better protect
against harmful pesticides and enzymes
called Esther aces and oxidases which
break down common insecticides making
them useless in fact researchers worried
we're running out of effective
insecticides if that's not terrifying
enough consider this just a few bedbugs
can quickly turn into a dangerous
infestation let's say a single female
spots you in the local movie theater and
hitches a ride home on your clothes
here's the problem she's pregnant and
will lay hundreds of eggs within just a
few months that lonesome bedbug can turn
into thousands but most victims won't
even notice until it's too late since
their flat plate like bodies let bedbugs
vanish and to impossible tight nooks and
crannies so it's no wonder infestations
are out of control from 2004 to 2009 the
New York City
council reported a 2,000 percent
increase in bedbug complaints and
although they don't transmit disease
bedbug bites are bad news in one case a
60 year old man needed to be
hospitalized for blood loss bedbugs can
also trigger itchy rashes which can
cause skin infections at best and deadly
allergic reactions at worst the good
news is you can rid your home of these
pests experts recommend hiring
professional exterminators to heat your
home to extreme temperatures of bad news
you'll have to shell out 800 to 1,200
dollars a pop to clear your apartment so
until we discover a safe but cheaper way
to take out every last one it won't be
so easy to sleep tight and not let the
bedbugs bite